une petite nation insulaire
au milieu de nulle part, sans voisins et sans trafic aérien.
D'où le choix de la Nouvelle-Zélande.
(Rires)
Voici donc pour l'infrastructure.
Le prochain sujet est d'ordre réglementaire.
Croyez-le ou non,
la Nouvelle-Zélande n'est pas connue pour ses exploits spatiaux
ou ne l'était pas.
Et on ne peut pas équiper un pays
avec ce qui est considéré comme étant un missile balistique intercontinental,
car hélas, si on peut mettre un satellite en orbite,
on peut aussi utiliser cette fusée à de mauvais desseins.
On se heurte donc vite à tout un tas de normes, de règles
et de traités internationaux
sur la non prolifération des armes de destruction massive et ainsi de suite.
Cela devient donc plutôt compliqué.
Pour que nous puissions lancer en Nouvelle-Zélande,
il a fallu que les gouvernements des États-Unis et de la Nouvelle-Zélande
acceptent de signer un traité bilatéral.
Et, une fois que ce traité a été signé
pour protéger la technologie,
l’État néo-zélandais a reçu beaucoup d'obligations.
Il a dû créer plein de normes et de règles :
des lois ont été adoptées par un comité restreint
puis par le Parlement et ont été précisées à terme.
Une fois les lois établies, quelqu'un a dû les appliquer.
Une agence spatiale a donc été créée.
Alors, les Australiens se sont sentis exclus
et ils ont donc créé leur agence spatiale.
Et ainsi de suite.
Comme vous voyez, une grande part de tout ça en fait,
les deux tiers, ne concernent pas la fusée.
(Rires)
Maintenant, parlons de la fusée.
Je ne vous ai pas dit
que nous sommes autorisés à lancer
tous les trois jours pour les 30 prochaines années.
Notre entreprise a donc plus de créneaux de lancement
que les États-Unis en tant que nation.
Et avec un lancement tous les trois jours,
il faut construire une fusée tous les trois jours.
Malheureusement, une fusée ne s'achète pas en magasin.
Impossible d'aller acheter des pièces pour la construire.
Chaque fusée est entièrement sur mesure,
chaque composant est entièrement sur mesure.
C'est un combat de chaque instant contre la physique.
Chaque jour, je me réveille et je lutte contre la physique.
Et je vais vous en donner un exemple.
Sur le flanc de la fusée, on voit une bande argentée.
Elle est là pour recouvrir des composants d'avionique.
Il a fallu diminuer l'émissivité de la couche
afin que les rayons solaires ne cuisent pas les composants.
D'où la bande argentée peinte.
Toutefois, quand on navigue à travers l'atmosphère terrestre,
on génère beaucoup d'électricité statique.
Et sans peinture conductrice,
on enverrait des éclairs sur la Terre.
Donc même la bande argentée doit être triboélectrique,
certifiée, appliquée, etc.
sans parler des plaques adhésives...
Même la chose la plus simple est toujours une vraie bataille.
Au cœur de chaque lanceur se trouve le moteur.
Voici notre moteur-fusée Rutherford.
Habituellement, on mesure les moteurs de fusées
en temps de fabrication, en mois
ou même parfois en années pour les très gros moteurs.
Mais en lançant tous les trois jours --
il y a 10 moteurs par fusée --
alors il faut produire un moteur très rapidement.
Il a fallu trouver un tout nouveau procédé
et un tout nouveau cycle pour le moteur.
Nous avons imaginé un nouveau cycle : l'alimentation par pompes électriques
et nous avons aussi réussi à imprimer en 3D ces moteurs de fusées.
Chacun de ces moteurs est imprimé en 3D en superalliage Inconel
et aujourd'hui, il est possible d'imprimer environ un moteur toutes les 24 heures.
Le cycle d'alimentation par pompes électriques
est une façon totalement différente d'injecter le propulseur
dans le moteur de la fusée.
La batterie à bord a une charge d'environ un mégawatt.
Et les turbopompes électriques ont la taille d'une canette de Coca-Cola,
pas beaucoup plus grandes.
Elles tournent à 42 000 tr/min
et chacune de ces turbopompes de la taille d'une canette
produit environ la même puissance
qu'une voiture familiale classique
et nous en avons 20 sur la fusée.
Ainsi, même la chose la plus simple, comme injecter le propulseur
est presque toujours un casse-tête.
Voici Electron, elle fonctionne.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Et pas qu'une seule fois : elle fonctionne souvent,
ce qui est pratique quand on a plein de clients à mettre en orbite.
En tout, nous avons lancé 25 satellites en orbite.
La cerise sur le gâteau :
nous pouvons le faire très précisément.
En fait, nous plaçons les satellites avec une précision de 1,4 kilomètre.
Si vous roulez en taxi,
1,4 kilomètre n'est pas très précis.
Mais dans l'espace,
cela équivaut à environ 180 millisecondes.
Nous faisons 1,4 kilomètre en environ 180 millisecondes.
Donc, c'est assez dur de faire mieux.
(Rires)
Je veux vous parler maintenant des déchets spatiaux.
Depuis le début, j'ai beaucoup parlé
de comment lancer très fréquemment, tous les 3 jours,
et des conséquences.
Mais, je ne veux pas rester dans l'histoire
comme l'homme qui a mis en orbite le plus de déchets spatiaux.
C'est le petit secret peu reluisant de l'industrie spatiale :
les gens ne se rendent pas compte
que la majorité de la masse des déchets spatiaux
ne sont pas des satellites, mais d'anciennes fusées.
Car lors de la montée en orbite,
il faut se débarrasser de morceaux de fusée
en luttant contre la physique.
Je vais vous donner un cours de mécanique spatiale débutants
sur comment aller en orbite
et comment nous le faisons très différemment des autres.
Au cours de la deuxième étape,
nous larguons une pièce de la partie supérieure, la coiffe,
et nous effectuons cette étape dans une orbite très elliptique.
Au périgée de l'orbite, le point le plus bas,
la fusée plonge dans l'atmosphère terrestre et se réduit en cendres.
Il nous reste donc la coiffe,
cette pièce blanche au coin de l'écran.
Elle a son système de propulsion :
on l'utilise pour élever et ajuster l'orbite
afin de déployer le vaisseau spatial.
Puis, grâce à son propre moteur, elle retourne en orbite rétrograde,
elle se remet en orbite elliptique,
elle revient dans l'atmosphère et se consume
pour ne rien laisser derrière elle.
Le reste de l'industrie est très sale,
ils laissent leurs ordures partout là-haut.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Je veux vous raconter une histoire
qui ne va pas me rajeunir,
mais je suis allé à l'école tout en bas de l'île du Sud en Nouvelle-Zélande,
une toute petite école
où nous avions un ordinateur un peu comme celui-ci.
Une petite boîte noire, un modem, était branchée à cet ordinateur.
Chaque vendredi, on se réunissait autour de l'ordinateur,
on envoyait un e-mail à une autre école aux États-Unis
qui avait la chance d'avoir la même installation
et nous répondait par e-mail.
On trouvait ça absolument incroyable.
Je me demande souvent
ce qui se passerait si je retournais dans le temps
pour m'expliquer à moi-même
tout ce qui allait se produire
grâce à cette petite boîte noire branchée à l'ordinateur.
On imaginerait que c'est tout à fait fantaisiste.
Et c'est précisément là où nous en sommes au sujet de l'espace.
Nous sommes sur le point de démocratiser l'espace
et nous venons d'envoyer notre premier e-mail vers l'espace.
Je vais vous donner des exemples.
L'an dernier, nous avons lancé un petit satellite
pour un groupe de lycéens qui l'avaient construit.
Les lycéens étudiaient l'atmosphère de Vénus.
Ces lycéens lancent leur propre satellite.
Un autre bon exemple :
il y a actuellement beaucoup de grands programmes
pour mettre en orbite de grandes constellations de petits satellites
afin de fournir un accès à Internet à chaque millimètre carré de la planète.
Pour à peu près tout le monde ici,
ce serait très pratique
car nous pourrions accéder à Netflix où nous souhaitons.
Mais si on pense aux pays en développement,
on pourrait diffuser toute la connaissance du monde
à chaque personne sur Terre.
Et cela aura un effet absolument considérable.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)